you know when the pilot asks you to keep
your seatbelt on whenever you're seated
it's good advice turbulence is the
number one cause of non-fatal air
injuries every year 58 people are hurt
across the United States when the air
suddenly turns violent a NASA study
estimates turbulence costs Airlines at
least a hundred million dollars a year
in injuries plane damage and delays and
it's only going to get worse studies
show that climate change will increase
turbulence across the Atlantic but there
is new technology that can help Airlines
have teams of meteorologists monitoring
conditions across the globe until
recently pilots would have been briefed
on the weather before their flight and
then lugged that with the rest of their
paperwork onto the plane in a briefcase
weighing about 40 pounds we used to
carry quite a few manuals on the
airplane for procedures or different
things that we needed as we were flying
around the world we digitized all that
and we had that right here and having a
tablet that brings in data in real time
is critical because on a 17 hour flight
to say South Africa a lot can change the
most exciting thing I have right now is
Delta developed this Delta flight
weather viewer and this provides us with
live turbulence forecasts and
observations accelerometers and pitch
roll and your sensors installed on the
planes measure bumps on a regular basis
and report it back to the ground being
online allows pilots to receive
turbulence reports instantly so that
others in the air are warned it's kind
of like Google Maps or ways but for the
skies you see an overlay of forecast
turbulence there's color coded along
this legend and here on the top but then
I can also tap on any one of these
observations and I can get detailed
information of that specific observation
tablets are just the start though this
concept from talus demonstrates a future
where the whole cockpit is a touchscreen
Tesla style
named avionics 20/20 this is a flight
deck that can be personalized and
reconfigured to suit each airline it
looks far-fetched but the French
aerospace supplier says it's technology
that could be made flight ready within
years because if we're in the back of
the plane using the in-flight Wi-Fi to
stay connected with the world shouldn't
the pilots be too